[Music]
you're trying to get people back into
just enjoying them in the music I've had
the experience when I go out and perform
in front of people where all I see is a
sea of iPads people put and you can't
even see their faces they're just
holding iPads up and you just see
screens because they're recording it for
later you're asking people look I'll
make all the video you're telling people
I'll make all the video available to you
but I want you to not shoot it while
we're doing the show
we tried that the last tour when we
started I asked if we could do that go
out and talk to the crowd and say would
you please just not take your phones out
let's just enjoy this with our eyes and
ears and and in people's that people are
gonna get upset and do it man
we tried it in people lovely people
applauded when we asked them for that
they applauded and all everyone as a mom
agreed we don't like this idea of this
practice because I think it's
distracting for the people in the back
who are trying to really watch and they
see a sea of blue screens in front of
them I mean them in the artist you know
someone told me it was in France or
something I think they were talking
about Iggy Pop or something did an
amazing jump into the crowd and some
amazing moment happened with him and
then everybody who was there all pulled
out their phones and were filming the
moment when nobody was in the moment
everyone was documenting the moment also
more importantly they couldn't catch him
but yeah better to be in the moment you
know I think and people are really
loving that we're doing that again on
this tour and other acts - sorry doing I
think Kanye started doing that too and I
think it's just it's just better that
way yes yeah definitely experience it
Lazaretto this is the new album what is
lazarette what does the Lazar Idol mean
I thought old history buff like you
would know that I didn't actually know
this one yeah this is a just came across
it - I didn't know it - like a few
months back it was a quarantine island I
was reading about the Black Plague and
this is this was just some light beach
reading I picked you on the beach in the
Bahamas I mean you have God you mean
you'll go and you'll have like the rise
involve the third right now it's
terrible that's like when I go out and
when I go out to someplace really fun
and everyone else is like kicking back
I'm always bringing you and I are like
that way a giant book about the darkest
subject ever and I'm wearing a crazy son
hat you I want to talk about what you're
doing with the vinyl which you've but
it's been so important to you but these
really are things of beauty you you
press these in Nashville you have your
own factory and you make these and you
put all kinds of special surprises yeah
vinyl to get people back into vinyl
there's actually a hologram yeah as a
hog here how does that work when you
spin it it's while this artist etched it
in with metal etching tools and we just
thought well if we can put as many
things as we could into this one record
what can we accomplish and we got away
with a lot of things it and discover new
things that had never been done before
it was this is a my proudest moment with
Third Man Records is this this this
object because we put our whole team
behind trying to make it happen you know
like the the the guy who is our master
cutter he also came up with an idea of
sanding the the master plate so that
this side comes out matte finish in this
side came out glossy you know just small
touches like that there's little it's
like God is in the details but when you
I've actually seen when you put the
needle on a certain part of the record
and it's turning mm-hmm they're a little
angel it's an optical illusion but it's
a hologram it appears to an angel hovers
over the record yeah it's one of these
things that I didn't even think was
possible yeah it's wild man I don't even
I don't know how it exactly works and
you can eat this this is a cookie also